[Music]
let's go out to Little Rock R Kansas and
talk to Tracy what's up
Tracy hi Dr John um thank you for taking
my call today of course thanks for show
thank you yes sir and I I love your show
and I just got your new book building a
non-anxious life I haven't read it yet
but I have it very cool um okay here's
my here's my problem I live alone and my
home is chronically cluttered
um to the point that I really won't let
anybody in my home um and this bothers
me really bad uh about myself about my
home and I'm just afraid that it's a
symbol of maybe a bigger issue that I'm
not seeing or else I'm just a sloth I
don't
know oh I don't think so um when you say
it's surrounded by
clutter is that
a is that a truthful statement or is
that a very nice way of saying saying
you're afraid you're a hoarder and
you've got trash and garbage and scary
stuff everywhere okay I'm not a hoarder
that yeah there's not trash like that
it's more like every um so it's not a
hoarder situation there's not too much
stuff it's just there's a lot of paper
sitting now a lot of mail that hadn't be
dealt dealt with or filing okay uh maybe
dishes on the counter in the sink um
multiple items on the Cofe table in the
bathroom counter just stuff that I use
and I think oh I put it up I'm just
going to use it again or I don't want to
file um who wants to file on your day
off um you know things like that but I
have a friend that when he comes over he
says your house is too cute for it to be
this messy okay and so that so it sounds
more messy than gross yes yes okay do
you collect things no no
okay so at my house I've got collections
of books and collections of music
equipment and guitars and collections of
hunting stuff so I've got things that
I've wrapped my identity around but it's
just tons of stuff and a lot of it's
really nice stuff but it's just
everywhere you're talking about you have
piles and junk and stuff and I just
don't want to put it
away yeah it's okay it seems like
another job if I'm off work uh to have
to go to and I keep thinking well I'll
just knock it out
out I'll knock it out I can get it clean
I'll have somebody come over and kind of
monitor me and make me stay task
oriented and I can keep it cleaned up
for a while and then it'll pile up again
okay um what does what does the Clutter
get
you what does it get me it makes me feel
anxious and stressed out and I yeah
there's something else on the other side
what does it get you you mentioned it
gets you some time off from what you
feel is like
work yes what does it get you you just
dropping the stuff where it is not
putting the dishes back not cleaning up
your stuff off the kitchen off the
bathroom counter what does that get you
oh nothing it digs me deeper in a hole
no I'll get you something or your body
wouldn't keep doing it okay um maybe
like an unsupervised
child how long have people been telling
you what to
do and what to think and what to
feel
um gosh I feel so independent uh it's
just this this is like my Achilles heel
and uh but you're not independent you're
not free no I'm not I'm I'm My Own
hostage in this house oh that's a good
word how long have you been a hostage in
your own home well I've been in this
home 15 years and I asked a friend of
mine recently how long has it been like
this because I thought before it was
because of the job I previously had
where I was a traveling sales rep and I
had a lot of work related brochure
sitting out but now I work from home now
and I thought well maybe it'll all get
cleaned up cuz I'm home um I have had a
health issue that's limited my energy
level and uh but that's I don't think
that's I can't even use that as an
excuse I just well and you see how that
becomes kind of recursive right you
don't feel super great so you don't pick
up after yourself and you open your eyes
and you feel stressed and immediately
like uh and then that's overcome with
shame and then you have less energy
and you do you see how it works one way
but it also works the other way but how
it works that one way tell me about your
home growing up what' your home look
like um it was perfectly picked up uh
there was nothing sitting out you
couldn't leave anything sitting out at
all but if you opened a drawer or a
closet you could see everything crammed
in
there and I will say it was a um
alcoholic home so there was some chaos
emotional chaos going on there you go
but everything was picked up and the
yard looked great
but it was all a facade yes sir just
like your smile was as a little girl
going to school yeah yes sir just like
you're probably a damn good salesman
saleswoman I did I did okay yeah you did
and nobody
knew right what do you do now I'm inside
sales what does that mean uh well I work
out of my home now but I'm still got a
sales position so I pretty much work
over the phone or the computer instead
of traveling pretty good at it yes oh
I'm okay I'm all right I ended up with a
a couple of health issues that kept me
from I don't have the energy level to
travel like I did
okay and I used to kind of think maybe
it was I'm older and maybe the health
you know
Health trouble so to speak um although
it's not completely debilitating um I
thought
maybe that's it but I've had a chronic
history of this of course you you said
something really important at the
beginning of this call that I want to
Circle back to and I want you to never
forget this as long as you live okay
okay you said I feel like if I clean up
on my day off I'm just doing work again
yes what that means in Reverse if I take
that as like a coin and I flip it to the
other side what you just told me is my
boss gets my first
fruit yes my boss and my job and my
customers are more important than me oh
wow it's my job to make sure everybody
else is taken care of and I'm not even
worth picking up the
garbage that's it and you know what you
grew up in the home of an alcoholic
you've been doing this your whole
freaking life yes sir you got it that's
it wow listen you have to flip that
around and say I can only serve my boss
and my customers and my family and my
kids and my friend if and only if I'm
whole and
okay and so the investment proposition
isn't that everybody get stuff in their
account and you'll just spend whatever's
left the investment proposition is I
have to make sure my account is full so
that I can go take care of everybody
else okay are you a Christian yes sir
there's a reason Jesus pulled away and
went and sat in the desert and prayed so
that he was anchored in and he could
repel off the edge and go be what
everybody else
needed and you're doing it the opposite
you're
right wow I knew I I couldn't see it but
you you've put it into perspective for
me here's the hard part it's hard to un
to reverse this and the cool part is
it's super doable okay all right I'm
gonna I'm goingon to give you I'm going
to walk you through a couple of things
that I think will help help
immensely is that cool I'm right yes sir
I'm ready I want you to are you creative
crafty not really but do you have a
friend who is I could yes y all right I
want you to get a friend and I want you
to pay him 25 bucks or 50 bucks or
something to make you a sign get one of
your buddies who's like one of those
woodworker nerds who knows how to
woodwork everything and they're great at
it get one of those friends okay and I
want them to make you a sign that says
don't forget to
remember okay and I want you to hang
that sign up in your living room right
when you walk in the door okay I also
want you to get that and write it on a
piece of paper or something or have a
small sign that you hang from your
rearview mirror or put it in your car
okay this was step one for me changing
my life okay here's why in the
moment when I'm starting to walk in with
a handful of like a a wrapper from uh
some food I just ate and a whole bunch
of books and the mail and my backpack
full of
junk I drop it down and then I go to the
sink and I grab something to eat and I
just drop the dish in
there and I literally don't see it right
then yes okay I'm just going from thing
to thing to thing and I'm tired I just
want to sit down it's when I get back up
from sitting down or get back up from
watching that show or get back even if
I'm trying to do something good I get
back in the house from that that
workout and I see all the piles of stuff
and my first thought is you're
disgusting what a
loser yeah I did same team uhhuh okay
the phrase don't forget to remember has
been transformative for me here's why I
see it in my car I don't have it there
anymore but I used to have it in my car
and I used to put it up in my house and
as I was getting out of my car I would
see it right as I'm getting out and it
would say don't forget to remember here
was what I was reminding myself don't
forget to remember how good it feels to
get into a clean car okay and then I
would stop and I would look and there's
two cups in my coffee and a wrapper of
some piece of candy I grabbed on the way
out and a book and and I just grabbed
all that
stuff and over time it became
automated okay just don't forget to
remember how good it feels to walk in
the door okay that's number one number
two I want you to create a new identity
for your
home okay here's what I mean by that
very similar to the call the first call
in today's show I want you to be very
specific and preferably talk to a friend
what do you want your home to feel like
when you walk in every morning when you
open your eyes what do you want to feel
like not what do you want to look like
feel like Airy light calm joyful fun
whatever it
is but I want you to start there with an
identity for your home this is my safe
warm fun laughter filled
place okay and so what has to be true so
that this can be warm and laughter
filled I got to throw that crap
away yeah but if you start with all
right every day I'm GNA throw all the
trash away that will last for about four
days yes in my house my wife told me
years ago when there's piles when
there's stuff everywhere I can't Brea
like
the way she described it is she inhales
real sharply instead of
exhaling yes and so I know that when I
pick up my stuff I'm telling my wife I
love
you see how much different that is one
is an identity one is a bunch of
chores and so if your home is a warm
joyful workspace slash Retreat
Center then crap doesn't come in the
door right I'm not bringing McDonald's
rappers into this warm safe lovely space
this is my retreat
center the same as you know like you
don't
put um motor oil on your toothbrush I'm
not putting that in my mouth okay I'm
not bring this in my house that's not
who this house is that's not who we are
here and that means I might sort mail in
the front yard and just throw it all
way I'm never going to get on a arp's
elite program I'm never gonna do that so
I'm not even bringing it in the house
yes I'm never going to buy another couch
on a credit card like I'm not hot so
that doesn't come in the house it just
goes right in the
trash see what I'm saying got it yes sir
I do all right number two I wish this
wasn't the case this is what I had to do
you got to get a friend okay and um as
my friend Don Madson the minimal mom
goes by and I would I would strongly
recommend checking her stuff out minimal
Mom I'm not telling you need to be
minimalist at all but but she does a
great step by step most of us when we
try to declutter we go after everything
all at the same time you just said I
just want to knock it
out yes your body over that's not it
gets overwhelmed and it shuts it down
yes exactly and then when it starts to
shut down Netflix is like I got
you and you just sit down there and turn
it on right exactly oh my gosh how do
you know me because I'm you right so
here's what we do we get a friend and we
pick one room and we might only pick one
wall of one room okay I'm just going to
clean this wall off I'm going get all
stuff off these shelves I'm going to get
all these books out of here I'm going to
get rid of all this stuff cuz my
identity is warmth and laughter and joy
not look how smart I am because I read
these
books and yours might be fill in the
blank right whatever it is okay okay but
get a friend and say hey we're going to
do one room and then I'm buying
coffee okay cool we're going to do one
half of one room then we're getting
coffee and they're going to want to push
you I'm here let's just go to the Next
Room nope it's what we got okay okay
we'll make it a process we'll have some
fun with it here is the um third
thing this is from fumio uh is it fumio
Sasaki I think it is a Japanese
minimalist um it's amazing what he said
he said all of our inanimate objects in
our home are having a conversation with
us 247
365 and so when you walk in the door and
you see the pile of mail
it's quietly Whispering hey Tracy are
you going to open us you just going to
leave us here in this pile think of all
the good deals we got you're going to
pay full price for that I bet we have a
coupon in here what if your old old
boyfriend from high school finally wrote
you back and said he loved you right all
all that and we don't realize that the
dishes are like Are you seriously not
going to clean us up you slob you
freaking lazy slob are you serious yes
right and so what I want you to start
doing is talking back
okay I am going to put you away dishes
haha or I'm watching a show I'm not lazy
I work my butt off today and I'm
struggling with some health issues I'm
going to watch this show and then at
6:32 I'm getting up and I'm cleaning you
up I'm putting you
away I can do that
okay sounds better than what I've been
saying to myself well here's what you've
been doing you've been talking to Tracy
not to the
stuff right
you got stuff in your closet that one
day you're going to lose the weight or
one day it'll come back in fashion it's
not Tracy it's not just it's not time
for it to
go and you're GNA have a friend that's
going to go through your closet with you
you're gonna buy them coffee it'll be
hilarious and sad you might cry it's G
to be all of that okay okay here's the
last thing all right
stop stop talking to yourself like
that yeah that is the last area where
I've really haven't handled the negative
selft talk I didn't even realize I was
doing it until we had this conversation
it never stops you are so mean to my
friend
Tracy and if you walked outside in your
front yard and heard a neighborhood guy
talking to his daughter like that you
would oh I'd come unglued I know you
would so treat
Tracy it's the reverse Golden Rule do
unto others as you would have them do
unto you okay you take care of others
you don't take care of you on the
inside so at least treat yourself as
good as you would treat a
stranger okay fair I can do that yes sir
oh my goodness okay and I can follow the
six daily choices and T my my promise is
if you'll go through those six daily
choices and begin to address
those you're going to have less and less
um room for trash in your house for
garbage just nonsense because your your
whole system will lighten
up that's what I've been trying to go
minim minimalist for a long time because
of that no that's like that's like
somebody just got out of knee surgery
getting rid of your crutches don't do
that okay you're right you might get
there eventually but people who just go
scorched Earth and get rid of everything
in their house and that stuff has become
an important part of of their body
trying to keep them safe and well okay D
you just go to the next Vice okay that's
why you go slow and that's why you go
with somebody and you process it and you
feel it okay do that you'll see you'll
see your buddy's face you'll see your
buddy's face and they'll be like oh my
gosh what is all this crap and you'll
feel embarrassed I want you to put your
hand on your chest feel the
embarrassment feel it okay and go yeah
I'm I'm getting
better yeah I wasn't okay but I'm on the
way after you get this whole thing
cleaned up I want you to take before and
afters okay will you send them to me yes
I'll be so
happy it's going to have to be in
sections Peace by piece by piece by
piece by piece we're going to do it in
sections it's going to be amazing Tracy
I'm super super proud of you and by the
way this will be two steps forward four
steps
back five steps forward three steps
back we're going to slowly make our way
to this okay this is a lifetime of you
putting everybody in front of you and
you're going have to practice over a
period of time finally loving Tracy
enough
to say no I'm it's not I'm not working
on my day off this is my first day of
the week and I work for me first so I
take care of me first and I make sure my
home is the safe wonderful warm Retreat
I want it to be then my boss gets what's
next we're going to flip this whole
thing
around so proud of you ah you're awesome
Tracy